I grew up in Canada I did so you've
gotta be you have you have to be yes
removed hasn't written removes have them
deported I love you
no seriously how did you I mean Canada
you gotta be used to the cold if you
grow up in Canada but I'm from Vancouver
which is which I don't thought it was
like the Bahamas yeah yeah did you did
you have to work hard to get rid of a
Canadian accent did you have a Canadian
accent I have like a slight Canadian
accent and I still do if I have a few
beers especially if they're Molson's and
that was for you guys yeah or if I'm
working with Canadians I was actually
working with some Canadians yesterday
and it just came out and it's so strange
you started just I just started yeah
it's it's it's the it's sort of your
outs becomes oats and you know that they
say Goodes yeah remember that no they
also say a hat is a toque yes this and
I'm right yeah when I was the times I've
been in Canada and I love the Canadian
people I really do but they'd be like oh
yeah sure Duke guy I got your ticket
like put your two car now I gotta know
what you're talking about what's it to
ya but I think it's fair because the Hat
is like a baseball cap or it's like a
woolen hat like we know what a - cos
it's like for the cold weather
call it a hat all right
agree to disagree you know Canadians
love to celebrate the fact that there
are Canadian celebrities and they love
to point that out all the time here's
the list of Canadians we did this we
made these yes there's a new documentary
yes called being Canadian huh and it
highlights the famous people from Canada
uh-huh and I want to show you a quick
sample this is just from the trailer all
right I just happened to see the trailer
okay take a look let's take a look
[Music]
okay here's the thing
yeah the filmmaker asked if he could
talk to me because he knows I'm a fan of
a lot of Canadian comedy so I thought to
me then I was I saw that trailer and it
really just like I'm not Canadian they
just put me in there and it's like
anchor Brian yeah
do you at all wish that you were
Canadian maybe he just kind of felt that
I mean I love that country I really do
so sure why not I'd let what I want is
the dual Passport
yeah I want to be an American who also
gets to go into Canada whatever I want
yes that's kind of what I got working
for me it's but yeah you always win
wasn't that a great clip subscribed to
my youtube channel for an endless supply
of me
[Laughter]